Hi! We have this question on our Quiz, where some
of you asked why it’s the convolutional neural
network’s depth that increases the receptive
field, or context window in other words.
This is a case where a picture is
worth more than a YouTube comment,
so here is the visualized explanation:
Increasing the kernel size in a CNN
also increases the context window,
since the output is directly
informed by more pixels.
But this would be a very costly
way to do it since the parameter
number scales quadratically with kernel size.
Having more of these kernels (or filters),
does help with feature diversity, but has
nothing to do with the receptive field.
But having a deep CNN with one
convolutional layer one after the other,
greatly increases the receptive field.
In a nutshell, if the output after the
first layer is this and was informed
by the whole region of 4 pixels,
then the next convolution layer
aggregates again 4 pixels, but now one of
them is already informed by four others!
Okay, bye!